These words having common.
There's a door in my house I never opened
even in October.
When I hear that strange knock knock,
your probably suspicious that things like these are lurking on the other side of
that door.
Words that hide the unknown,
but you're not scared by playing lexical items.
I mean you need context and narrative.
A scary story.
The kind that has an unknown [inaudible] psychologically intimidates your
characters.
Add plus one points.
If the medicine is linked to wider social ills,
a sense of despair or hopelessness that comes over your audience as they fear
that the menaces to powerful,
to handle a McGuffin,
a person or object that drags us into the depths of fear without distracting us
from the main story.
A plot twist for added suspense,
and if yours is a psychological thriller,
add another plus one.
If by the end we find out that the narrator telling us this true tale is also
unreliable.
So there's your scary story checklist,
good night,
happy Halloween.
What?
Where did it come from?
Okay,
sure.
The storytellers of old knew how to spin tales with monsters and ghosts,
like in Homer's Odyssey,
spirit possession in lady Merce sockies tale of Genji or even spooky settings as
Dante's inferno,
ancient Sanskrit,
drama theorists,
even shrewdly separated that personal feeling of anticipation you have sitting
there alone with your heart beating faster,
faster,
and faster from the shared sentiment of error that descends over the entire
audience and the reaction of follows.
But these high artists,
we're focused on telling a perfectly balanced tale,
not indulging our fears for hours on end.
And then there's folklore,
local lowly tales of the shape shifting us Swang haunting the forest of the
Philippines
or of spirits exiting the other world to walk the earth during the Celtic Salad.
So in the very same harvest holiday behind our Halloween ha folklore and a whore
are both full of strange,
mysterious supernatural tales.
But the path from one to the other isn't really direct.
It took her reaction,
the kind that happened in the enlightenment as you're up grew more and more
rational,
sophisticated,
and then romanticism reacted with pure,
raw emotion.
Usually those emotions were nice emotions,
but of course not all emotions are nice.
One of these emotions was the sublime,
the immense shock and all you feel when looking at mountains are huge gothic
buildings.
Philosopher Edmund Burke talked about this.
The idea of horror and terror being feelings of the sublime pain and terror are
capable of producing delight,
assault of delight for a sort of tranquility,
twinged with terror.
We want to be scared.
We enjoy it.
How sublime novelists took this dark emotional journey and created the gothic
trend around that time turning medieval castles,
towns,
priests and monsters into objects here over time,
novels,
movies and games capitalized on these dark emotions to engineer our scary story
checklist,
take that funny word,
McGuffin.
Sure our story needs a menace,
fear,
uncertainty and surprise.
But Alfred Hitchcock thought,
what if we add an extra item that grabs our interests and pulls us along?
Here's a recent example,
sort of reason I was little,
little skeleton key may not ultimately determine whether or not the spirits in
the attic loose snatch our bodies tonight,
but it certainly keeps us curious long enough to stick around and find out what
happens next.
Modern horror uses elements like these to tighten our experience of fear from
start to finish.
So from folklore to rationalism to romanticism to gothic to modern horror,
we have a whole history of scary pros to thank for this basic checklist,
we've come to love or fear,
love to fear.
So if price gets
to my channel,
critical links to find out more.